alex trebek announced his cancer battle
over a year and a half ago but his
passing still feels like it came so
quickly yeah kev that's because no
matter how much he was hurting we still
saw a man doing what he loved to do most
and as i found out from one of the
people closest to him it remained that
way
until the very end
[Music]
at the end of the day what is the one
thing that you want people to take away
from you
that i'm a very lucky individual
i'm good at what i do now i'd be lying
if i said the journey
had been an easy one there were some
good days
but a lot of not so good days
this was the last time alex was spotted
in public in july
at the hospital a day after his 80th
birthday
the game show legend hosted more than 8
000 jeopardy episodes
his final day in the studio was just a
week and a half ago
those shows will air christmas week and
executive producer mike richards told me
it was incredibly emotional behind the
scenes
we had chills the entire time we didn't
know that they were going to be
his last shows he had had a surgery
he had been out for a couple weeks he
gives a speech at the beginning of the
monday show
talking about the importance of being
together loving each other
and the importance of family when did
you learn that things had turned for the
worse
i believe it was friday that he said
that his son should fly back in which he
did on saturday
i knew saturday that things had taken a
turn
on sunday just after the news broke of
alex's passing
his wife of 30 years gene and his
daughter emily were spotted outside the
family home
he had a nice final day he was out on
his swing
that he loved with his wife
and surrounded by family it was a very
peaceful day there were laughs
and then he went to sleep the tributes
continue to pour
in legendary jeopardy champ ken jennings
wrote i'm grateful for every minute i
got to spend with him
steve harvey called alex the classiest
game show host of
all time and kelly and ryan devoted fans
i played jeopardy with him every night i
remember for me when i first moved to
los angeles at like
19 years old merv griffin let me go
watch him tape shows just a remarkable
legend that will uh
never be forgotten so what's next can
jeopardy go on without alex
will the show come back in the new year
yes absolutely that is the one thing
he made us promise that this great show
was not done
he did not want to be bigger than the
show producers are not sharing details
about a new host right now
it's a discussion alex stayed out of he
never mentioned names to us
he really wanted to be the host of the
show while he was the host of the show
so we didn't say hey what about this
person or what about that person
and we haven't and there will never be
another alex trebek
as we saw just last thursday during the
pre-taped show
this contestant from india fought back
tears
any family members back home uh cheering
you on
you know here's a true story man uh i
grew up i learned english because of you
and so my grandfather who who raised me
i'm gonna get tears right now he
we i used to sit on his lap and watch
you every day so
it's a pretty special moment for me man
thank you very much
alex was an inspiration to so many
especially in the way he fiercely fought
cancer
from the very beginning
[Music]
this week i was diagnosed with stage
four pancreatic cancer
march 6 2019 the announcement was
heartbreaking
the cancer diagnosis came after alex was
tested by his doctor
for pains in his stomach and after it
was over he came to me and said alex you
were right
there was a bulge in your stomach the
size of a small fist
i'm going to fight this alex decided to
share his cancer battle for a very
important reason
i wanted to stay ahead of the tabloids
because i knew they'd be getting
involved
with all kinds of misinformation
determined to fight alex began
chemotherapy and shared all the ups and
downs
overall i'm improving my numbers are
improving
and i'm very positive about the outcome
i lost about 12 pounds in a week
and my numbers went sky high
much higher than they were when i was
first diagnosed so
the doctors have decided that i have to
undergo chemo
again audiences never knew how much he
was suffering
i was on the floor writhing in pain it
went too
i went from a three to an 11 and it
happened three or four times
that day while we were taping
[Applause]
i taped the show and then i made it to
the dressing room
on one occasion just barely before i
writhed in pain and cried
in pain i had 15 minutes before the next
show
so i got myself together and the
producers were very kind they said look
if you
if you don't want to do the show we'll
just cancel tape i said no we're here
we're doing the shows
just two months after his cancer
announcement alex won his seventh emmy
award
and proved he hadn't lost his sense of
humor alex
i'm aware that there must be a fair
amount of sympathy
that went into the voting for this but
to tell you the truth
i don't care i i've got the award
and i enjoy having this award
alex was also lifted by prayers from
fans all around the world
and this surprise moment with a jeopardy
contestant
proved how much the support truly meant
to him what is we love you out that's
very kind
thank you costco
19.95 you're left with five bucks okay
one thing they will not say at my
funeral is
oh he was taken from us too soon i've
had
one hell of a good life and i've enjoyed
it
and the thought of passing on
doesn't frighten me it doesn't
other things do the effect it will have
on my loved ones yes that bothers me and
makes me sad
but the thought of myself moving on hey
folks
comes with the territory
[Music]
you